what's your drink of choice
water past 10 p.m. also water yeah uh I
might go for um Diet Coke with ice and
lemon I like that as one right if you
could be number one in the world or if
you could be number basically if you
could be the greatest of all time at
anything else what would it be soccer
for sure soccer okay that's an easy one
do you have a dream sponsor um my Puma
deal is expiring so um I'm open for um
open for new ones in that um sector but
I I would recently at the Jordan uh golf
club so if Jordan Jordan want to come
and sponsor me I'd consider it every
other chess player has said any sponsor
because we don't get sponsorships I'm
sorry for my um you destroyed two
decades of chess players back sorry
about that